Darcie how are you I'm good Conan how
are you I'm doing really well I envy you
it's like a Balinese chair you're in
right now
yes I'm just feeling the ocean air no I
don't live great I like old downtown
from here that's what you could just
tell people no one would know that's
true it looks like you've opened a spa
it's just vanity looks I'm getting
relaxed just looking at you how are you
doing how are you during this time I'm
I'm good
I'm I'm I feel like I sort of have it
you know I'm not an essential worker in
any sense of the word to uh nacelle and
I don't have kids so I'm like I'm doing
a lot of cooking I'm doing a lot of
eating I'm doing a lot of television
walking watching walking and walking dog
walking you're clearly you're falling
apart I can tell I can tell
actually this is like the first time I
put on makeup and brush my hair you look
great
tell me I know I become friendly with
you and you're a very cool husband Jason
yeah and I'm so I know you guys you're a
very cool couple in fact my wife and I
tried to hang with you guys
unsuccessfully right hold on Coenen
reach the pandemic happened yeah yeah we
didn't want to nobody wanted to rush
each other was like you want to throw
out a date I'll throw out a date cuz
this weekend no let's next week it's
like the it's very it's what we do you
don't mean nobody solidifies anything
it's like guys will do it at some point
I suspect you and Jason of releasing the
virus just to get out of it that's
because the timing was so suspicious you
were like yeah maybe next week unless
Mary you said unless there's some sort
of novell virus from the corona family I
think that was part of it you think that
that was that you were working in a lab
at the time okay sure but you have no
proof honestly you know we I mean
honestly truly it kind of puts it all in
perspective of like when this is all
done let's like let's hang let's jump on
the French
doesn't mean hang what doesn't mean I
don't know but I don't know I think this
means fight okay I know what it means
okay um are you you two then yeah side
or you just to stay you have it I mean
you have to go outside right it's so
funny how like a dog walk is one of the
biggest parts of our day it's so
important you know when there's so
little to do that becomes it becomes
like the most important thing that we're
doing during the day we I don't know
we're wearing where I'm I wear them oh
my dog's right here you know it's funny
as you were talking about your dog he
your dog crashed the zoom in the
background this is penny
what's the name penny penny hey penny I
love Penny's rakish scarf thank you she
is not loving this vibe right now she's
like I think penny entered thinking it
was one show then so I was like I'm good
I'm good I liked him in the late 90s
yeah okay I'm out of here
yeah go for a dog walk what is your
manner because you're a very chipper
cheerful person I am
I imagine you being that way out in the
world even during the pandemic you know
what's funny is I think that I am
friendly in normal life but the mask is
giving me almost like this um boldness
like I can't I truly cannot pass a
person without greeting them in some
sort of way there's this guy the other
day that was playing the saxophone
really beautifully and I sort of like
yelled across the whole park I was like
sounds good
sir I'm just saying I I question first
of all saxophone that's you literally
spit into a sack and fire
saliva out into the world it's a giant
brass saliva shooter he he's truly
spitting he was just spitting into the
world I'm just amazed droplets hearing
here's the thing here's the thing I went
for a walk yesterday and I was wearing
the mask but I also like to wear this
big crazy cowboy hat in Australia when I
was doing a Travel Show and it's a
Crocodile Dundee hat and I do this thing
now where people pass me and I do that
what I'm saying and I realize I'm doing
a character who I don't know I'm like a
I'm a cordial bank robber
you know 1880s a hundred percent also
it's smart of you to wear the hat
because if your hair is so recognizable
even if you had the mask on they'd be
like hello mr. O'Brien yeah I see you
there
I know I know I kind of the boldness
goes both ways so I'm nice to people but
also if someone isn't wearing a mask or
if so either day I saw some like four
guys together walking
nobody was very masks right right and
I'm like this doesn't check out what do
you brothers like what's going on you'll
live together this is a no you're
walking so closely I can tell they're
not roommates this was not like a
brother situation it was like something
something's up here so the mask gives me
a boldness I mean it doesn't actually I
don't like go up and yell at people but
I do feel a little bit like more
powerful so I can't see